it would seen a North Korean leader who
might just be the first to blink well
John you could say that but you could
also say that what we heard from the
Trump administration the top diplomats
on Monday was that they were putting
diplomacy and economic measures first
that they were pulling back from this
this very bellicose rhetoric we heard
from the US president last week the
basic fact is neither side wants to go
to war Kim jong-un does not want a war
he knows that he would not survive a war
he knows his country would be
annihilated it's been made very clear by
the United States and the United States
and certainly South Korea don't want a
war Seoul would be hit extremely hard
there have been some very devastating
estimates of casualties so the basic
fact is both side has been quite
bellicose in their rhetoric neither side
though actually wants this to go further
that it absolutely has to before they've
made their point now we heard from the
South Korean president moon jae-in just
an hour or so ago its liberation day
here liberation for the Japanese
occupation ironically a day that both
North and South Korea celebrates that
they're both United on this particular
day and he did say during that time that
if it was up to him and it is up to him
war will not return to the Korean
Peninsula okay we urge North Korea to
stop worsening the situation immediately
stop provocations and threatening
behavior there must be no more war on
the Korean Peninsula
whatever ups and downs we face the North
Korean nuclear situation must be
resolved peacefully I am certain the
United States will respond to the
current situation calmly and responsibly
in a stance that is equal to ours
the North Korean are saying they're
going to wait and see what the Americans
do next are obviously referring to next
week where there's going to be u.s.
South Korean military drills the US so
with general Dunford here just yesterday
already said they will go ahead and
every time they do annoy North Korea
it's just a case of this time how much
higher the tensions are and how much
more the North Koreans could be annoyed